okay so the topic of this video is the
genetics inheritance pattern known as
known as autosomal recessive inheritance
so let's get started
so here's the Henderson family they've
been happily married for eight years the
square represents Dylan the male and the
circle represents Maria the female okay
so they have a six-year-old daughter
named Sophia because Sophia is female
the circle represents Sophia they also
have a three-year-old son named Nicholas
because Nicholas is a male we use a
square to represent him in the diagram
and they just welcomed the birth of
little baby Joshua because Joshua is a
male we have another square in the
diagram so that diagram represents the
five members of the Henderson family and
here's their doctor who has helped them
through the pregnancy and says hello
Henderson's please sit down there's a
situation we need to discuss you know
newborn babies are often tested shortly
after birth with hopes of detecting
certain genetic disorders and Joshua
sadly has tested positive for a disorder
called phenylketonuria PKU more commonly
called PKU and he informs the Hendersons
that PKU is an autosomal recessive
genetic disorder well mr. Henderson says
you know it's been a lot of years since
high school biology class what does this
mean what is a horizontal recessive
inheritance mean and our doctor says
well let's start with the word AutoZone
here is a karyotype it's a picture of
the person's chromosomes perhaps
Joshua's chromosomes and if you recall
when we learned about karyotypes earlier
in the school year the X and Y
chromosome here are the sex chromosomes
of a male but the other chromosomes
chromosome pairs 1 through 22 are called
autosomes and so in Auto
is a nun sex chromosome it's a
chromosome that has no genes on it that
influences one's gender and so autism
with disorders are caused by a gene
found on one of these 22 non-sex
chromosomes here if a gene is found on
the X chromosome or the Y chromosome
it's called sex linked you know maybe
you've heard of the disorder called
hemophilia hemophilia is an example of a
disorder caused by a gene on the X
chromosome hemophilia is what we call a
sex linked disorder now that's something
we're gonna learn another day but today
we're focusing on the autosomes you know
one example of an autosomal disorder you
might have heard of is sickle-cell
disease it's an autism because the gene
that causes sickle cell has been located
to be found on chromosome 11
notice how chromosome 11 is an autosome
so sickle cell is an autosomal disorder
and if you're familiar with sickle cell
disease you know normally red blood
cells will roll and travel freely
through the blood vessels but for people
who have sickle cell the red blood cells
are a Mis shape and they're kind of
deformed and so they're less likely to
roll freely and they carry less oxygen
they're more likely to clog and the
reason that this is called sickle cell
disease as the red blood cells are often
sickle shaped kind of like you see in
that picture there so they're misshapen
well you know another example of an
autosomal
autosomal disorder you might have heard
of is cystic fibrosis well why is cystic
fibrosis an autosomal disorder well
that's because the gene responsible for
cystic fibrosis has been located to be
found on chromosome number 7 you know if
you're not familiar with cystic fibrosis
you know here's kind of an overview
normally the cystic fibrosis protein is
made from 1480 amino acids and that's
what those circles represent our
the amino acids all chained together to
make the Cystic Fibrosis protein and so
normally when the protein is made the
amino acids will twist and fold and wrap
into this 3-dimensional protein here but
people who have cystic fibrosis
unfortunately they're lacking that 508
amino acid out of the chain of 1480 and
as a result when the protein twists and
folds and wraps its shape is altered
just a little bit and that sadly causes
the disorder called cystic fibrosis you
know one of the more defining features
of people with cystic fibrosis is that
their lungs often fill up with a mucus
which then becomes a breeding ground for
bacteria and it causes a lot of strain
on their health
well our henderson family they're seeing
the doctor today because they've just
been told some news that their newborn
child has PKU phenylketonuria PKU is
another example of an autosomal
recessive disorder
it's autosomal because the gene has been
located on chromosome 12 the gene
responsible for this disorder is found
on chromosome 12 chromosome 12 is an
autosome PKU
is a disorder where people don't process
an amino acid called phenyl alanine
normally phenyl alanine gets processing
changed into another amino acid called
tyrosine and tyrosine bonds with a bunch
of other amino acids to make a protein
called melanin but people with PKU they
lack the enzyme needed to change
you know alanine into tyrosine so what
happens is the phenyl alanine des starts
to build up and build up and build up in
the person's bloodstream and this
actually interferes with the person's
brain development and can cause some
very serious mental disabilities if not
identified and treated so the fact that
our little cartoon Joshua has been
identified at birth is actually a very
a good step in treatment and so the
Guthrie test this is a blood test
performed on infants to test for PKU
it's a blood test and this is how our
little cartoon baby Joshua was diagnosed
so let's go back to our story here
how did Joshua mrs. Henderson wants to
know how did Joshua obtain this disorder
both dillon and her are fine and so her
are her other children Sophia and
Nicholas they don't have PKU so how did
Joshua obtain this disorder well the
doctor says let's talk about genotypes a
person can either be homozygous dominant
and that would be to capital letters to
represent the alleles I J I happen to
use the letters H in a moment and you'll
see why or another example of a genotype
a person can be homozygous recessive to
lowercase H H's and you'll see why I use
the letter H again in a moment or
there's the possibility that a person
might inherit one dominant allele and
one recessive allele and this is called
heterozygous and when it comes to
autosomal recessive inheritance the rule
is that sufferers of these disorders
must inherit two alleles one from the
mom and one from the dad in order to
have this disorder that means healthy is
dominant and the disorder is recessive
and that's why I use the letter H when I
do my punnett squares whatever the
dominant disorder is that's the letter
of the alphabet I have chosen since
healthy is dominant I chose a capital H
to represent healthy and therefore the
lowercase H would represent unhealthy or
having the disorder now I know that mr.
Henderson is healthy so he has to be one
of those two combinations right there
he's either homozygous dominant or
heterozygous same from mrs. Henderson
she's healthy from the story she said
she's healthy so she has to be one of
those two combinations because the lower
company
the two lowercase H's that's how the
person would have the disorder well mr.
Henderson and mrs. Henderson do not have
the disorder but their child does so
Joshua has the disorder
he must be - he must have two recessive
alleles he must be homozygous recessive
well where did he get those two
recessive alleles from he had to get
them from his parents even though even
though mr. and mrs. Henderson are
healthy they each must possess a
recessive allele and they each had to
pass this recessive allele on to baby
Joshua that's how G how baby Joshua
inherited this disorder well what about
their other children maybe Sofia is
heterozygous maybe she inherited a
dominant allele from one parent and a
recessive allele from the other but
maybe Sofia is homozygous dominant
we just don't know all we know is right
now from this story all we know is that
she's healthy she does not have the
disorder same with Nicholas their other
child here we know he's healthy from the
story we were told he was healthy but he
could be heterozygous maybe he got a
dominant allele from one parent and a
recessive allele from another or maybe
he's homozygous dominant maybe he
received a dominant allele from each of
his parents we don't know for certain we
just know that Sofia and Nicholas are
healthy and so let's examine a punnett
square we learned earlier that mr. and
mrs. Henderson both have to be
heterozygous they're healthy but they
still produced a child with the disorder
so when we fill in the punnett square
you can see that there is a 3 out of 4
chance to produce a healthy individual
but a 1 out of 4 chance to produce an
individual with this disorder
and so the odds that little baby Joshua
inherited this disorder PKU was only 25%
one square out of four but sadly it
happened and so mrs. Henderson says does
that mean that Sophia and Nikolas each
had a 50/50 chance of being a carrier
when they are born
notice the punnett square two squares
out of four would result in a carrier a
heterozygous individual and the doctor
says yes as did Joshua Joshua had a
50-50 chance of being a carrier as well
unfortunately it didn't work that way
for him unfortunately Joshua inherited
the disorder if we look at this pedigree
right here squares represent males and
circles represent females so we already
know that mr. and mrs. Henderson are
heterozygous one way that we can
symbolically show this in a pedigree is
to partially color in the square and
partially color in the circle for Dylan
and Maria that means that they're
carriers they're heterozygous well we
know they had each of them had to pass a
recessive allele to baby Joshua he has
the disorder and so in a pedigree what
we tend to do is we tend to color in the
circle or the square circle if it's a
female square if it's a male if they
have the disorder now with Sophia and
Nicholas again we don't know their
genotype we know they're healthy so they
have to have one capital H but we don't
know what their second allele might be
well mr. Henderson wants to know well
what can we do now to help Joshua now
that he's been identified as having the
disorder PKU our doctor says you know
PKU can actually be treated by following
a special diet I'm gonna schedule a
meeting with the nutritionist they can
teach you proper care of little baby
Joshua and thank you for your help today
doctor and that's kind of the end of
this story right here okay so try to
answer these five questions you know
pause the video when you're ready hit
the play button
and let's go over them together I'm
gonna go over the answers in three two
one
so the story says that Maria is
heterozygous so that's her genotype one
uppercase letter one lower case letter
so I can add her to my punnett square
question number two what is Geoff's
genotype well the story said that he
suffers from cystic fibrosis so he has
to be homozygous recessive I can now add
him to the punnett square so when I fill
in the four punnett squares here I can
now answer questions three four and five
number three what's the probability if
they produce a healthy child two squares
out of four 50%
what about number four what is the
probability that they have a homozygous
dominant child I hope you see the answer
is zero homozygous dominant would be to
uppercase H's none of the four punnett
squares have that combination and then
number five what's the probability they
have a child born with this
life-threatening disorder that is also
50% two squares out of four have the
homozygous recessive combination
and so there you go I hope that helps
under helps explain what autosomal
recessive inheritance it is if you're in
my class you know pause the video try to
answer these nine questions here I'm
happy to check your answers before
school or after school one day and thank
you for watching